hi everybody welcome to the Reuben
report I'm Dave Rubin we have a crazy
breaking news jam-packed edition of the
show today there is so much stuff going
on in the world right now you know some
weeks not that much going on we got to
pull a story out of our butts not this
week there is just a ton going on things
are changing as we speak so we're gonna
get right to it I've got two great
guests with me I've got miss Jackie
Geary and Miss Vanessa Gomez and there
is so much to talk about a lot of Egypt
stuff but we're gonna start with Alec
Baldwin I have to do this story because
of everything that I've been tweeting so
we all know basically what happened he
he was at James Gandolfini's funeral a
reporter thought that his wife was
tweeting during the funeral which
actually turned out not to be true and
then Alec went on his latest Twitter
tirade let's read them all right so from
the bottom up in chronological order I
want to I want all my followers and
beyond to straighten out this [ __ ]
little [ __ ] George stark George stark
was the the writer who tweeted that his
wife was tweeting my wife and I attend a
funeral to pay our respects to an old
friend and some toxic Brit writes this
[ __ ] trash I put my foot up your
[ __ ] ass George stark but I'm sure
you dig it too much I'm gonna find you
George stark you toxic little Queen and
I'm gonna [ __ ] you ah truly a lovely
lovely fella all right so before we get
into I just want to say I ABS I'm a
comedian I am a talk show host I believe
in free speech you can do whatever you
want you can say whatever you want short
of you know yelling fire in a movie
theater and basically threatening
violence which he pretty much did so I
would always be around the side of free
speech so I don't necessarily think that
that's what this is about ladies where
does this loon like howdy how are you so
rich and entitled to get whatever you
want all times and still so angry
Jack II have no idea it's so depressing
and horrible and I love him why does he
make it so hard for us to love him well
that's impossible yes immediately and
evil chicken sad
twisted as a humanlike keep it together
man yeah how do you I really I have so
much trouble every time I read it looks
like this sticking the foot up the ass
and let that's an IQ right that's where
it crosses it for me I can't I can't let
that go that's that's some rage filled
hate right there is that the part that
makes it homophobic to you cuz the toxic
queen part I could see you could work
your way out of it with the tried to but
you tried to save me was referring it
refer to anybody as a queen to somebody
thinks that they're better than some
right so we'll get to his apology in a
second but is there is to put the foot
up your ass in a tweet that's the part
that makes it more homophobic I mean
look I think this isn't the first time
that he's gone on a tirade I mean this
is not News at eleven you know we know
that alec is capable of doing this but
yes I definitely think that that was the
tweet that broke you know the camel's
back it's like it was so unnecessary and
it was it was visual I mean that's part
of it you know you have a picture in
your head and and yeah you're right I
mean I think that that was the tweet
that was really the what put over the
edge I think if he had just tweeted
maybe the other things like you said you
know I'm gonna f you up or I'm you know
that's trash it's not true what he said
I mean obviously he's defending his
pregnant wife so I wouldn't say that
people would think it's uncommon or
unfair to you know defend his wife but
definitely he went way over the line
right so let's well let's look at his
apology and then we'll and then we'll
jump back in so here's what he said the
idea of me calling this guy a queen and
that being something that people thought
is homophobic a queen to me has a
different meaning it's somebody who's
just above it doesn't have any
necessarily sexual connotations I know
women that at Queenie I know men that
are straight that are Queenie and I know
gay men that at Queenie it doesn't have
to be a definite sexual connotation or a
homophobic connotation to me those are
people who think that rules don't apply
to them this guy could blatantly lie I
mean blatantly lie about my life on the
Internet and there are just no rules
that apply to him but that's outrageous
to me now the irony of this is that alec
baldwin is the one that thinks no rules
apply to him remember the phone on the
plane
then that whole thing so even in that
apology he really didn't address what
we're all agreeing is the the more
egregious comment and the threat of
violence right just stop talking stop
tossing you've done enough stop talking
don't try to invent your own dictionary
for what words mean in our society well
I think the term dick really just refers
to people no Richard yes what how I see
the word shut up stop talking that's not
an apology yeah do you guys think that
he's getting off on this because he's a
well-known liberal activist he's
obviously left-wing the media loves and
left-wing media loves him blah blah blah
and as hilary rosen of former CNN
correspondent said he gives money to the
right cause and she was actually
defending him and i know her I've had
her on my little Sirius XM show and I
was sort of shocked at what she was
saying cuz basically she was saying look
he gives money to gay causes so let him
let him say whatever he wants is that
acceptable no absolutely not acceptable
incidentally I don't think he wrote that
apology that's like two different people
for one so what just start there like
that was completely eloquent and and
different than the person who was
writing the tweets but yeah I think that
that would be maybe a good excuse that
he's thinking oh I give money so I have
the right to do you know it doesn't
matter whether you give money or whether
you said it doesn't mean it's okay yeah
for him to have said what he said it
just doesn't yeah now relating this to
everything that's going on with Paula
Dee and I know they're not exactly the
same thing but we vote we have two
public figures who are both being well
one attacked and one let go by things
that they said one racial one homophobic
is this is the thing with Paula Deen is
this purely because she's a Southern
woman so there's this you know again
this is sort of a left-wing media or the
mainstream media they can easily attack
so a woman from the south when it's
related to a racial thing but it's a lot
dicey er to attack sort of one of their
own about about even something gay
despite all the good gay stuff that's
going on lately yeah I mean I think
that's where it gets so tricky is
because even myself just as a human
loving Alec Baldwin as an actor and all
of work he has done it's so hard for me
to be
when I read it again it helps but I
somebody had pointed out if he was a
conservative right and hadn't given to
all these causes and was a different
person it would be it would be
outrageous and people would be furious
like if Sean Hannity had said this I'm
pretty sure there would be riots outside
of Fox News never want to defend Sean
Hannity which I think - is that Paula
Deen is herself she plays herself she's
not an actor like Alec Baldwin is we
don't see her in any other way like we
do Alec Baldwin we think of him and we
think of the great roles how funny he is
this shows he's been on all of that
stuff so I think that has a little bit
to do with it and absolutely the fact
that he is you know liberal obviously I
don't think that he's homophobic I
really don't genuinely as a person just
if you come from where does that imagery
come that he obviously the guy has anger
management issues to say the least and I
think that when he gets angry he
obviously doesn't think before he speaks
I mean we saw that look at the rage that
he did towards his own daughter do you
know any means so if if that was okay to
do that and attack his own daughter I
mean anybody's game and so I'm not
saying it's you know obviously I'm not
condoning it or anything like that but I
think he just has anger management
issues and he says things out of anger
that maybe aren't rooted and you know I
think he loves his daughter obviously
but you hear that voicemail and you
would think different yeah so I don't
know but I really would love if if his
sponsors came out and said something all
right so we'll get the capital one in a
second but before that do you think that
that this is really about a word because
Paula Deen said the N word which we
universally know you know you shouldn't
say you shouldn't think that whole thing
now he didn't say [ __ ] which is now
becoming the new F word but do you think
if he had said [ __ ] that that then
would have at least coalesced all the
the gay groups I'm glad not to have
immediately exonerate him if he had
actually said the word do you think that
that might have been you know instead it
was this imagery but not a word I like
are we so dumb that yeah it's it's kind
of messed up that in not using the word
he kind of skated by a little bit even
though the what he had texted about the
foot is so Rachel right so rage filled
in so much
but yeah somehow he was able to skirt
around it and word choices
I don't know how yeah yeah I feel two
ways about it I feel on one sense yes
that's obviously a hot-button word it's
a trigger word if he would he used it I
think people would have come out a lot
stronger but the other thing is we have
to remember that Paula Deen she sort of
attacked a community of people it was it
wasn't one person it wasn't in defense
because she was provoked or anything
like that I think the difference is Alec
Baldwin though he messed up he was
provoked this person did write something
that was extremely slanderous and not
okay about his wife and is there
anything more disrespectful than that to
say that you read a funeral and you know
we're uplifting or tweeted about
smoothies or whatever it is they know
not to be true not to be true so I think
people also take that into consideration
like you know Paula Deen was using these
racial slurs because she wanted to throw
a plantation party I mean you know so I
think it's that and also unfortunately
and I know that I'm not gonna be the the
you know the good guy on the panel to
say but I think unfortunately we're
still in a nation that people are more
okay with gay slurs and they are racial
slurs and I wish that weren't the case
but I feel like we still are on that
right we're still on that balance that's
the irony of the whole thing because we
had all this great stuff happened with
DOMA and then this is happening at the
exact same time which shows you that
everything is a long process but ok I
want to talk about capital one just to
close this thing so Alec Baldwin you
know he does those over-the-top
commercials with Capital One Capital One
has not issued a statement they've
actually ignored dozens of my personal
tweets and they've ignored thousands and
thousands of other people's tweets and
emails and comments and I know people
from Forbes magazine and others have
been trying to reach out to them to
comment but they've ignored everybody
which may be to Vanessa's point that you
still can say things about gay people
and companies don't have to do anything
I actually called Capital One a couple
times they hung up on me twice the third
time the rep said that he was on
vacation so he didn't know what was
going on and that they couldn't get me
in touch with anyone else so I paid off
the tiny bit that I have left on my
capital and credit card and will no
longer be using it and
little something right it's a little
yeah my $25 credit limit with you people
Discover Card I'm on my way yeah but
okay so then final thought on this do
you think it's just ridiculous that
Capital One doesn't have to just all I
wanted them to I didn't want them to
fire him I don't think people should be
but that they don't to say anything they
haven't felt any pressure to say
anything is that is that a bigger
problem here than almost the initial
they're not recognizing that he did
anything wrong I think that's maybe what
bothers you that they should come out
and say either one way or the other
we're going to support him yeah stand by
him or we're gonna fight him whatever
but they need to say something because
something was done wrong or them not
saying it she loses all her cookbooks
the TV everything except for her
magazine I think societal I think if it
was 1962 and somebody used the n-word
like Paula Deen nobody would comment on
it either and everybody would be like
well okay you know and just and just you
know and I think hopefully in 40 years
nobody will be able to get away with
anything like that again I think a
perfect ending to a bizarre topic